-Today is Friday,
and that's usually when I catch
up with some personal stuff.
You know, I check my inbox,
return some emails,
and of course I send out
thank-you notes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I was running a bit behind.
I just wondered
if you guys wouldn't mind,
I'd just like to write out
my weekly thank-you notes
right now.
Is that okay with you?
[ Cheers and applause ]
James, can I get some thank-you
note writing music, please?
[ Somber piano music plays ]
-No, no, no.
Something different.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Happy piano music plays ]
[ Questlove laughs ]
-Ooh, wow.
-Sounds like a level
of Mario Bros.,
where he's in, like, a
dreamland, like when Mario's --
-Get a coin, and he goes
into the drain.
-Yeah. Let's go to the other.
I like the other one better.
[ Somber music resumes ]
-Yeah, that's perfect.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, CDC,
loosening restrictions
for vaccinated Americans
for reintroducing the world
to the bizarre and elusive
concept
known as making plans.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, Bernie Sanders
greeting Joe Biden
at his speech to Congress,
for being the first fist-bump
in history
where you hear 10 knuckles
crack at once.
[ Laughter ]
"My hand!"
-"My hand fell off."
-[ Laughs ]
"Here, take mine."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, the Kentucky Derby,
for letting me know what NASCAR
would look like in 1896.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hurdle by a stretch.
[ Hoofbeats ]
-And the winner is Beetlebaum.
♪♪
Thank you, mint juleps,
for being the closest
I've come to eating a salad
in the last three months.
Yum.
-Minty.
For you health.
♪♪
-Thank you, number-one NFL Draft
pick Trevor Lawrence,
for being the first quarterback
to get an endorsement deal for
both Nike and Garnier Fructis.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-My gosh.
-I won!
♪♪
Thank you, lox,
for tricking me
into eating sushi at 9:00 a.m.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Nice try.
-Glad you thanked lox.
♪♪
-Thank you, U.S. Census,
for being the government's
version of a nosy neighbor.
He lives with how many people?
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
-Okay.
Just don't see
that many cars there.
Interesting.
♪♪
Thank you, The Census Bureau,
for sounding like an '80s
New Wave band
that never quite hit it big.
[ British accent ]
"We're The Census Bureau."
♪♪
"This is our first song.
We love you.
We're The Census Bureau.
Good night, everybody!"
♪♪
♪ I gotta get to the Derby ♪
♪ Gotta go real hard ♪
♪ I don't have a car ♪
♪ At least The Census
don't know ♪
♪ I said
The Census don't know ♪
-♪ The Census don't know ♪
-[ Deep voice ] ♪ Listerine ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Somber music resumes ]
-[ Normal voice ] Thank you,
racing hoods for horses,
or, as horses say,
"Guess who's Zorro now, bisch?"
[ Laughter ]
What?
-That's what they say?
-I have no idea. I have no idea.
-And you're thanking them
for it?
-[ Chuckles ]
-You thanked a horse...
-What's that?
-[Laughing] ...for saying...
-Yep.
-...for saying,
"Look who's Zorro now, bisch?"
Okay.
♪♪
-Thank you, toasters,
for having two settings --
raw dough and volcano rock.
There you have it.
Those are my thank-you notes.